hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to go with you through yesterday's
press action on amc we had some very
nice bullish price action so let's see
what this means in terms of future price
action let's get into it
[Music]
so bam bam bam first wave okay let's
take a step back here so first wave went
to 23 then we corrected for three months
then we got back to the seventh level
73 and then we had this long correction
that last around two three months and
then we had the breakout finally so this
was the signal that things are starting
to go higher so
now
let's zoom in a little bit and see where
we are in terms of waves development in
this fifth wave i'm not sure it's the
fifth of this move one two three four
five or is it the major fifth one two
three four five but it doesn't change
much in terms of targets so
what we're interested in so first maybe
i will give you back the targets again
so we use fib extension we apply one
plus one point six one eight to the one
plus three so let's take it from here i
think it makes more sense and so it goes
roughly to the 130 level sometimes it's
a one-to-one relation so it would be 90.
so those are my targets 90 130 for the
coming month roughly
this would be a coming month
now let's see what is the probability
that this scenario actually happens i
mean not really probability but let's
see what the market what kind of signals
the market is giving us so we are
looking for bearish or bullish signals
and then we're gonna see what is the
conclusion so for now this looks like
the first wave right one two three four
five okay
the third is a bit short but it's still
longer than the first it's a valid
counting i'm not gonna keep it to have a
light chart
so this would be a second so one abc so
i was not sure so it still can happen i
i'm not sure if the second is complete
or not all right we could have an abc
that's possible but it's unlikely
i think that what we have is an abc like
this and this is already one two of a
major third right
maybe something like this that would
make more sense to me
so we're not there yet we need to break
48 on the upside first but once again
guys when a resistance has been hit
twice and we come back to it uh it's
usually weaker this is what creating
this type of pattern all right the cap
and handle we have something like this
here and of course if you have an upside
breakdown it would look very good so
what can i tell you here i can tell you
that 40 is still support we have one
more support here now
one two you see we hit twice 42.4 so i'm
going to keep it here it's our
short-term support we have a medium-term
support a bit lower to me we are really
nicely set up let me check the volume to
uh make this third of the fifth okay
if we have nice volumes it's even better
okay
volumes are decreasing
but
they're still substantial all right we
had 100 million shares trading yesterday
and this is the highest close we have
seen
for the past uh almost two months guys
all right
so it's good it's looking nice to me now
once again if we break 42.5 on the
downside we might correct a bit longer
now let's have a look guys on the
synthetic short interest all right
because we know that this is where the
gamma is coming from and we also know
that
this is what is going to create a lot of
buying
orders by market makers on the upside so
let's have a look at that so here we go
guys
21.2 this is the maximum synthetic short
interest so i'm monitoring this data the
maximum i've seen was 23 so we're close
to it uh we have right now nine percent
of synthetic short once again i've shown
you guys this before but it's very
interesting to see where this is coming
from we can see that uh basically we
have a lot on september all right which
strike fully strike all right so this
created some troubles for market makers
and we have on september
you see we have the 50 strikes so the 45
and the 50 strike on september are huge
and we have the 60 all right so this is
going to create a lot of troubles for
market makers if we push higher all
right this is a lot of gamma guys and we
can see that if it doesn't work it's
september we already have a lot of
options on jan 22 especially on the 145
strike so this is the reason why the
exposure of market makers is um shorter
on the upside and that's why they need
to buy
so let me here show you an updated chart
okay so the option distribution looks
like this guys so
down you see 145 strike is absolutely
massive all right the biggest one before
that is here around 8 million and here
we have 20 million so this is of course
very expensive for option holders but
this is the reason why the bullish
momentum is gonna intensify on the
upside if we keep pushing higher which
is happening right now even if the moves
are not that big yet it's going to the
right direction and once again on
september this is coming from september
all right all this uh strikes sorry
maybe not this one
uh but all those all those ones this
one's here like 45 50 60. it's coming
from september so the show to the
maturity the bigger the gamma so this is
as well something that is if we break 48
on the upside
it's
like almost sure that we go to 55 and
probably 65 let me show you the chart
again those are the targets for this end
of week if we break here
i mean i don't see what can stop the
price to go right away to 55 and if we
do market makers will have to keep
buying so let's see maybe we're gonna
have some sellers taking profits here we
don't know but definitely it's gonna be
to the advantage of the bulls and one
more thing i wanted to tell you guys
about something i told you already a
long time ago when this uh was very low
i'm talking here about the high uh
dollar which is a cryptocurrency created
by a group of friends that are in hong
kong i mean one of them is a friend not
a very close friend but he's a friend
and those guys they created this crypto
i gave you guys this opportunity long
time ago and i just wanted to show you
how good this is going for now they have
one million members so in a matter of
like two months something like this so
it's a lot it's growing fast uh the
price of the high dollar is now 0.70 it
was trading at 0.2 0.3 when i told you
about that i'm not sure this will
skyrocket right now because as i told
you guys on my discord they have long
term ambitions so they don't want the
idol to go too high too quickly so
you know there's going to be some
selling pressure
that might come if this goes too high
too quickly but it definitely has a very
very nice potential so i just wanted to
show you this again for those who
haven't seen and if you're interested
just click on the link in description of
this video and you can subscribe and get
free high dollars every day so that's it
for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore i'll see you guys